clark county school district reaching a
tentative agreement with the largest
teachers union and this allows for the
possibility of some of our younger
students and staff
returning to the classroom in january 8
news now reporter kristen drummond shows
us what to expect if the plan is
approved by the board of trustees next
month
the plan right now focuses on the
district's youngest students so
those who are in elementary school ccsd
says pre-k through third grade students
may
possibly return first for face-to-face
instruction
next year our babies need to be in
school
they're the ones that need the social
interaction a big step in bringing
students back to schools for in-person
learning the district and clark county
education association came to a
tentative agreement
following months of negotiations the
plan outlines certain standards and
safety precautions
that includes mandatory covet-19 testing
for educators
and providing personal protective
equipment cca's executive director calls
reopening schools a trial and error
process but
this allows for an incremental approach
being
ready with a plan is absolutely critical
and we think this is a plan that allows
flexibility
allows us to address emergent issues
that suggest
maybe we expand maybe we contract the
district will not require students to
take a covid19 test before coming back
on campus
as for the vaccine the district plans to
work with the southern nevada health
district
to make it a voluntary option for
educators the tentative agreement will
be presented at the board meeting
january 14th
trustees will also consider a potential
reopening plan on that date
until then all staff working remotely
will continue to do so
reporting in las vegas kristin drummond
8 news now